there are troubling new developments in
ukraine as russian bombs shells and
missiles hit heavily populated areas
video released by the ukrainian
government appears to show civilians
caught up in an attack on a government
building in kharkiv ukraine's president
is now accusing russia of war crimes in
the meantime a 40-mile long convoy of
russian military vehicles is on the move
north of kiev those reinforcements could
indicate a major new russian offensive
is imminent
charlie daggett is in keefe with more on
this part of the story charlie this is
just very upsetting to watch this in
real time as it's progressing good
morning to you
it is gail thank you good morning to you
because it's getting worse by the hour
president vladimir zelinski doubled down
as you said calling the strike today in
kharkiv a war crime saying in the state
uh calling state terrorism on the part
of russia and saying that the defense of
a capital here is now the key priority
a huge missile slams into the city
administration building in car keys
freedom square this morning the number
of dead and injured is not clear at this
hour but people are believed to be
buried under the rubble and a rescue
operation is underway it's the latest
salvo in what has become a full-scale
russian assault on ukraine's second
largest city including a series of
indiscriminate rocket attacks that rain
down on dense urban areas the interior
ministry says dozens of civilians have
been killed
ukraine's ambassador to the u.s accused
russia of using weapons banned by most
countries they use their
um
vacuum bomb today which is actually
prohibited by geneva convention so you
know the devastation that russia is
trying to inflict on ukraine is is
largely
in a late night address ukrainian
president zielinski described what he
called the bombardment of kharkiv as a
war crime laying blame on president
putin himself
many fear the russian president at the
end of his ever lengthening table is
becoming more isolated unpredictable and
dangerous by the day
the civilian death toll is climbing
this six-year-old girl was injured by
russian shelling while out grocery
shopping with her parents doctors fought
desperately to revive her but she could
not be saved
now the capital itself may be in the
crosshairs of an all-out battle new
satellite images show a massive 40-mile
russian military convoy on the move from
the north russia's advance is leaving a
trail of destruction in its path
wrecking villages and suburbs on the way
ukrainian forces have put up stiff
resistance so far holding ground despite
being outgunned and outnumbered
but the real test lies ahead as the war
enters a dangerous new phase and this
city of more than 3 million people
braces for the battle to come
what many fear is an aerial bombardment
of the capital and overnight the
ukrainian president pleaded for a no-fly
zone the white house has already
dismissed that saying that is not a good
idea
nate
charlie dagida and keith thank you